[Music]
david
when
in a metal ceremony started
and they announced our name
this is gonna sound so vain and so
little of me but my crowd was louder for
us
the audience was mostly
western that's why i was not surprised
i remember just standing there
looking out at the panel the judges that
were still sitting there for the medal
ceremony going how dare you
how dare you
ugh
so we get out there and we're putting on
a smile and there comes our canadian
flag on the side this is not what i
dreamed of
i'm sure i was crying
i really
had a soft spot for jamie and so when i
saw her
on
on the podium and and
she was just trying to be so brave
in her heart knowing that her dream was
taken away from them
[Music]
deep inside there is a disappointment
but what are you going to do about it in
front of millions of people
you know
life is unfair
at that point you're not looking at all
the marks and what judge is sitting
where and where they placed you
but we're second that's all that matters
we're second
after the podium ceremonies you always
skate around take some pictures and then
a french cbc commentator waved at me and
his words were
it's the french judge it's a french
judge
i could feel frustration in his voice
he was mad a lot of people backstage
were mad
it came down to the second mark the
artistic mark
and it was five judges to four
and
you could say that the deciding vote was
the french judge
it was very difficult because i was the
swing judge
it was the eastern bloc and the western
bloc and that's why before salt lake
city as a french judge i was supposed to
be part of the western bloc and i have
rejected that
that's that political aspect because i
wanted to be fair to the schedule
you have to make a choice and you have
10 seconds to take your decision so
that's crazy
just crazy because it was so close
the russian pair has a new program with
a creative choreography new music and
it's very impressive
for sure there was a small error of the
russian skater or the the double axel
but it's just a small error you don't
judge only two seconds of the
performance you judge four minutes of
the performance and the canadian prayer
it's an old program love story
it's very important to skate another
program with a new choreography every
year
so i have decided to have the russian
pair on the first place
maybe it's a mistake but it's like that
we wear five judges against four judges
it was a nightmare really it was a
nightmare
anton and elena could you address
whether you felt that was a gold medal
performance
yes sure because we have a gold meal
[Music]
[Music]
you